hello reject nation we are going to talk
about Maleficent mistress of evil the
movie where they turn what a Disney's
greatest villains into a hero wicked
style here's the plot description from
IMDB just to make my life easier
Maleficent and her goddaughter Aurora
see what they did from the first movie
begin to question the complex family
ties that bind them as they are pulled
in different directions by impending
nipples yeah not too hot enough jewels
unexpected allies and dark new forces at
play here's what my plot description
would be roar is engaged
Maleficent don't want her to get married
to this family there he goes and that's
about it then poop hits the fan general
thoughts on this movie that was fine
there's a fair amount in the Pro column
a fair amount in the con column it's all
right there are things that occur in
this movie that to be frank of all this
movie's not exactly full of surprises
there are things that would be spoilers
to really break down what I don't like
things that are just like questionable
but like they're like funny dumb to me
you just walk out complaining about it
but it's not like Oh irritating me just
like the way these characters responded
or reacted to these devastating
situations then there's things you
question at the end of the day you go in
a movie like this it's all dependent on
your expectations
you know the mystery element of it was
intriguing enough I love the designs in
the movie it looked beautiful like the
film just look gorgeous long it's like
sweeping aerial shots and I was really
impressed by those because there were
times where I had to really question how
much of this was visual effects and how
much of this was sets that were built
was any of it health service or anything
like New Zealand style exteriors or
anything like that yeah cuz it looks
great this film is definitely darker
than the first one I'd say the first one
I remember having a lot of humour
actually to it with this movie when the
plot kicks in it pretty much stays in
it's darker realm and continues to get
darker till the finale don't go into the
spoilers about stuff but it's pretty
it's pretty dark tone film for Disney
live-action
weirdly the the biggest impression this
movie left on me or the thing I came out
thinking of the most was I wonder who
this is truly aimed at before the movie
started they had a big graphic on the
screen and I realized oh and I'm we may
have even talked about this in the past
and I forgot but this movies PG watching
it I started to think that there's a
clash between the way it is written in
the way it is realized it delivers its
information in a way and I don't want to
be patronizing when I say this but it
delivers its information and steams in a
way that suggested to me that this was
aimed at kids sure the movie itself felt
like the hard PG is like a pg-13 really
because it's a dark war fantasy it's in
its aesthetic sounds like it really
wants to be like a heavy Lord of the
Rings style epic by the end of it that
clashes with the elements that are
supposed to be more digestible for
children the plot handles itself and the
way that motivations handle themselves
is always very clear who is evil who is
good yeah even in the mystery it's like
if you're a parent watching this or if
you're just an older audience member I
have to imagine that you know pretty
much where everything's going it's not
too muddy in terms of its context yeah
to be you know above anybody's head that
being said it has moments of fantasy
that work and look really beautiful I
feel like everything they try to do
works at some point it just came out so
uneven to me that I couldn't tell ya
which level they wanted to exist on
because okay you got essentially two
different things are exploring in this
movie Aurora's engaged to Prince Phillip
getting to know Philips family the movie
lets you in on a pretty early on they're
like they're the mom Michelle Pfeiffer
ain't really there's other plot where
Maleficent begins to discover her roots
hurt her kind of her lineage her people
her destiny you're exploring these two
different things and then within there
there's some pretty solid performances I
think Elle Fanning does a really good
job in this movie I think she shines a
lot more at what she did in the last
film whenever Angelina Jolie is on
screen she's gray she made to play this
as much as you might feel I guess she's
still not evil or rude but she still
really commands the screen whatever
she's on even when she's given like the
super subtle moments she's really good
and there's a scene
in here kids if you're listening I'm
about to swear there's a scene in here
with Michelle Pfeiffer and Angelina
Jolie early on on the movie where I can
only describe it as they're trying to
out [ __ ] it's great it's like really
well acted moment watching them how
totally fun like Michelle Pfeiffer the
way this movie writes her the OneNote
the writers had seemed likes make her
more Mieville she's completely two-faced
she's completely is either kind to the
point of suspicion or she's just evil
spoil one minor thing but this is just
to tell you how silly her character like
Michelle Pfeiffer is actually really
good she sells this as hard as Charlie's
Theron did in snow inland they're just
lines they give her they're just so bad
evil villain has a secret spot section
where she has her secret thing and how
would nobody notice her secret section
that she has in order to access it it's
a mannequin and she would see this I can
see why you wanted to install this for a
legitimate purpose other than villainy
yeah sorry if that's like or something
that I ruined for you my point with that
is every problem I had with it I just
found funny nothing
angered me nothing annoyed me there are
times where the pacing of it was a
little flat a little dull because the
movie is it does take itself really
serious yeah which was kind of a
surprise but like I said because there's
a real lack of it seems that first that
it was gonna bring like humor and stuff
but then that it kind of is vanishes
then in the middle of doing these
explorations and heavy exposition scenes
as you'd expect with a film like this
Maleficent kind of disappears for a
while he like took the longest bathroom
break or something because there is a
point where the craziest stuff in this
movie is happening and then when they
finally cut back to her I had a thought
of yeah this is this isn't the Aurora
and Prince Philip try to thwart you know
correct yeah there were things that
surprised me that I enjoyed I think one
of the Achilles heels is I think this
movie misplaced its focus and I think it
should have changed the proportions to
where we spend most of the time on the
personal journey with
Maleficent because it seems like she's
actually going through something kind of
profound with the other Fae like but
again not too much detail but that's an
actual character thing and she's so
great at the character and kind of a
mistake to get consumed by the kingdom
plot they set up this really fun thing
with Maleficent and this personal
dynamic that she could have wood that's
conflicting with Aurora but then as the
movie progressed it seemed to shift all
of its focus on to its other characters
but then it's like but it's still
Maleficent movie so we have to put some
more focus on her ending arc journey
didn't really leave an impact on me it
felt like it happened in a subplot
all the character growth in all the big
moments very much seemed to be divided
by the script needs them to have them
more than you know the finale of this
there's some bleak things especially in
its context it gets to be a war movie
it's a fantasy warm like it gets really
I was surprised a surprise for a
live-action Disney film that had got
like oh wow they really kind of went
there do I like bloody and gory we're
doing like war mongering genocide yeah
it's pretty awful allegory on a
technical level though I think if L knew
what it is the last like 10 minutes of
this movie could have been done a lot
better because that's I noticed what
everyone was kind of making fun of was
the last few minutes of this movie with
the way they handle the resolved or
whatever you want to call it the wrap-up
so there's a lot very much like we're
moving along now don't think about yeah
I think she would toll Ejiofor is wasted
in this movie he's cool because like
nobody the exposition guy they gave a
lot more character to ed skrein than
they did to chew it's all Ejiofor yeah
ed skrein kind of did what you would
expect from ed skrein new Jai Courtney
people like slightly more than Jordan I
still enjoyed it for a movie that took
itself so serious and I surprisingly had
a fun time when I was watching it this
was like a thing I caught on Netflix or
something I think I would have been like
really intuitive been like that was a
lot better than I expected it to be the
Maleficent films about gave me what I
would I think if you like the first
Maleficent you know just like a good
family-friendly movie there's a hard PG
I'm gonna coin that
right now I enjoyed my time there were
definitely things that I appreciated
that dazzled me I mean I think Disney
right now and their live-action
fantasies like this are unparalleled in
terms of production design realizing
that design with sets and an CG but you
know costuming and tangibility this
movie I really feel like either ought to
have been a hand-drawn animated movie I
feel like as it exists in the way it
exists with the tones and the writing
the way they are I feel like it really
could have been cohesive as a hand-drawn
movie or I feel like they should have
really doubled down and gone like for
the pg-13 why a crowd with this but yeah
dark antihero Evil Queen is like prime
for that territory and this subtext they
want to go for is like complex enough
that I feel like it would it be better
served there I mean there were there are
times where they did like they went
darker than I expected but they but the
landing of things are they ultimately
chickened out on left the movie actually
said one of the things I was saying was
I would have liked this a lot more if
they actually do bleak by the end of the
movie yeah commit to being a hard pg-13
or yeah make it some kind of animated
movie where the fence it's like The Lion
King in a different way it's like
because it's live-action it because it's
real it is more intense even if there's
not blood you know it's like it's much
more tangible and I feel like if you
look back at a lot of these classic
films that this is based on those
animations we all look back as adults
ago this is a lot scarier and more
intense than we ever imagined as kids
and so I feel like that illusion doesn't
hold up as well in live-action I'm sure
people are gonna have some some fun with
this and there is definitely a lot of
beautiful imagery and imagination yes
play and Angelina Jolie is incredible
alright guys well do you think we should
do a part three Maleficent misunderstood
never come back in like you know 20 more
years is like an older woman old woman
Maleficent yeah and I have three
generations of bad ass Fae human peeps I
love your thinking John thanks you guys
can subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell and catch you
guys soon